hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i am very excited
to find out
what games i enjoy online games
specifically as a woman that i enjoy for
anyone who missed the like kerfuffle
surrounding this particular article um i
am currently having to
access it on an archive because it was
taken down
basically a website called parade
published this punch my microphone
basically a website called parade
published this and e3 tweeted out the
link and e3 would obviously be followed
by
a lot of women who work in the video
game industry and make pc and console
games at things that are
known for having more hardcore audiences
so it's just like such a weird choice
for them to do that
doesn't make it wrong i guess we'll find
out but i'm sure that yes a lot of
women play the games listed in this
article i also
hot take don't think you're any less of
a gamer if you just play mobile games
that's cool with me
you play whatever you want let's [ __ ]
do it shall we already off to a start
that i sort of hate
girls love gaming just as much as men
according to a report by the
entertainment software association which
is the esa
of the total 214.4 million players in
the u.s 41 percent of female
77 of women ages 35 to 54 say playing
games helps them to relax at 78 are
using their downtime
to hop into alternate worlds on their
smartphones
or devices or devices
i mean this is very clearly written by
someone who doesn't
play video games right like you would
think that well maybe it's that parade
doesn't have a game or audience at all
like it goes without saying that playing
online games can be an amazing
distraction from a long day on the job a
much needed break from intense news
headlines are a way to engage with
friends and loved ones with this
friendly side with a side of friendly
competition we know
okay let's go they said we surveyed game
developers pro gamers and everyday
players to bring you this list of 25
free online games for women i can see
the first one you guys can't yet and
while i don't have an issue with the
first one
i think i'm gonna take a lot of issue
with this sentence as this goes on
first up sudoku i do
[ __ ] love sudoku [ __ ] i am a woman
you got me there did you guys see that
channel
where the guys do like really difficult
sudoku
it's like incredible content i highly
recommend it also
you're gonna get me on the second game
sayonara wild hearts
also rules so [ __ ]
i'm a stereotype it slaps i don't know
what to tell you
ah there it is there it is number three
on my list of online games that i play
as a woman
a gamer in 2019 64
crandy crush in 2019 64 of candy crush
players were female and as the days go
by more and more women seem to become
hooked that's actually not that many for
a game that has such a stereotype of
only women playing it 64 percent
i bet you these dudes are [ __ ] just
there's a bunch of bunch of you watching
this
a bunch of dudes watching this who love
candy crush but aren't willing to admit
it
that's my logic that's what that mean
harry potter wizards unite
i did play a little bit of this because
i do play a lot of pokemon go i feel
like this one probably came out of
nowhere though i would think that this
game
like sure i know women who play it but i
would think it's
like not predominantly what are these
stats that you got from the people you
surveyed did they just list some games
and then you put them on here like what
what
what is the order what does it mean i
love
how it let me keep playing in the harry
potter world beyond the
books says say
sarah bean a book marketing manager
in michigan who plays alongside adult
animal crossing new horizons [ __ ] yeah
dude
yeah no good it's a fun way for jennifer
chatfield who manages media relations
for a large hospital system
who where did they get these people why
do you have a
book marketing manager and someone who
does media relations from a hospital
where are you finding these people are
these just your personal friends
i haven't visited my island in months i
bet they all
[ __ ] hate me it's been like two
months i made the video the youtube
video where i did an island tour and
then i
bounced which okay maybe
they don't have a right to be pissed off
because i made them like a luxury
[ __ ] island it's beautiful
and then i left so i did all the hard
work and i didn't have to do anything
and now they just get to read through
what i take it back i'm not sorry animal
crossing island
oh the watch oh and then solitaire
overwatch has become
extremely popular with ladies who game
you don't say it actually is true
i feel like overwatch is like a
specifically interesting one in that the
hero design like
women can really [ __ ] get behind it
which like you know obviously isn't
required i don't know girls were like
hardcore into cod and
whatever the point being there are so
many women playing so many
games now that an article like this is
outdated and that's why it's so silly
because even from when i was in high
school where it was like you know
better i i told the story in a podcast
the other day i remember the moment
where i was like oh
the fact that i am a woman who plays
video games is not
cool is when i was telling a story about
dead rising
frank west and killing zombies in a
shopping center and i was just like
talking about what i had done the night
before to one of the girls that i was
friends with
and she was like you know what i used to
pretend to care but i just don't give a
[ __ ]
um and i had this it was like my glass
shattering moment of oh
talking to people about video games
isn't actually
normal like it is with film or tv
it's actually pretty weird that i'm
doing this to a person who doesn't play
them
i'm socially awkward i am but now i feel
like no one would be surprised they'd be
like cool what's the game
about women like it since it has a lot
of female heroes to portray giving them
a chance to hold their own amidst the
boys and for
its fantasy element
who did you survey for that is that why
women like overwatch
because it has a lot of female heroes
i don't know if that's true boss it
might be the gameplay
players can portray everything from a
time traveling freedom fighter or a beat
dropping battlefield dj my two
favorite fantasy elements
i digress solitaire still good [ __ ]
you know has been around since 10th
century
china everybody likes solitaire can't
complain can't complain
sims 4 you say uh look
i also unashamedly like the sims the
sims
franchise has been around for just over
20 years
offering its users the chance to live
life however they
like i want to kill myself when i do
that voice why
did you interview a catering assistant
from england
is it because you're just trying to show
diversity of
women here is that the point that's
probably the point
stardew valley all right okay hey
okay you guys you can even propose to
someone
that you think is marriage worthy that
is
all women want next up spelunky
[ __ ] yeah spelunky is an old-school
platformer game that's i don't like
platformer game
erase this let's get rid of this i don't
feel good about
that being there or your character must
make their way through different levels
starting with a cave hence the name
and avoid being killed by numerous
amounts of monsters awaiting you players
like drury
enjoy using it as an escape from daily
stresses and feel a huge satisfaction
when completing a level great
we like spelunky number 10 hot [ __ ] ah
oh oh no
ah
diamonds are a girl's best friend
am i right ladies
i like don't even know if there's much
that i give
less of a [ __ ] about than diamonds
and they are even more fun when they
come in a variety of sizes neon colors
and when you get rewarded for properly
matching them
like people like bejeweled you just
all of this i hate why it's a go-to for
many gals
i hate it i hate it i hate it bang dream
girls band party who the [ __ ] is this
this game originated in japan and became
so popular the us recently got its own
version
bank dream combines animated characters
will be what the [ __ ] is this game
wow it has a persona 5
that's you got me interested i like
persona 5. is that on the list
um yeah it's a music game when you tap
on your phone to follow the rhythm of
the songs
joe flanagan founder of 90s fashion wild
and an avid gamer has seen this one be
popular for the opposite sex
casino world what are these quantified
by as if
what like are you trying to suggest that
women like casinos more than men because
that's probably
not true star chef cooking game
women do belong in the kitchen quick
question
who is this for
like look
i get it if you get assigned a feature
sometimes you just have to write the
feature this could be sponsored
maybe i don't know i just who is this
helpful for
like who is looking for this information
on this [ __ ] website where it's
literally in the headline it says online
games for women
who is benefiting from this this list
which again i'm not saying women don't
like these games i'm sure there are
women who play these games but it is a
very specific
narrow view of things from what i can
tell the spelunky isn't it
and animal crossing we take the wins
where we can i just don't know who's
who benefits from this existing you know
what are we learning this is not for
people who play video games which is
like really uh for [ __ ] sake
kim kardashian hollywood adventure
create your own celebrity story join kim
kardashian in hollywood
this is the tagline of the popular game
created by the reality queen herself
this game was really [ __ ] popular i
don't know what it is fashion
and stuff maybe i don't know harvest
moon
people like harvest moon too right so
farming and [ __ ] yeah nice
nice jessica forsyth nice house flipper
just dance 2020
disney code illusion oh
that one stinks really
really stings the eyes
who says coding is just for males disney
definitely doesn't
this is actually if this like is
targeted at young women
pretty dope i'm in support of disney
making an app that teaches young girls
to code by using like disney princesses
or whatever 70
of all people who have purchased disney
code illusion are female
that's neat 30 dollars a month
oh [ __ ] all right disney game of life
everyone loves that
drawful too that's got to be like a
massive mix of
just sort of everyone owns that game
love letter huh
you and the suitor are competing
bachelor style to get your love letter
to the princess now you must bluff draw
and play to her affection
excellent the last game on the list is
tetris
i do love lining up block squares and
other shapes watching them fall and
striving to get them all in a line
okay but really i mean as silly as this
is from my perspective as someone who
plays video games
every single day or whatever you know
it's fine
this is yes a fun thing to make fun of i
think that's mostly what i saw online i
don't think i saw that people were being
actually genuinely outraged i do think
e3
tweeting a link out to this article is
really stupid and
again i'm sure there are plenty of women
who do play these games i have no beef
with it you know
you go ahead play what you want fam this
is obviously not written for me
and for me well definitely some moments
of pain
um most notably
[Music]
diamonds are a girl's best friend am i
right ladies